décembre 95 la france est paralysée
partout dans le pays les murs de
banderoles très solides qui vont faire
reculer le gouvernement d'alain juppé le
premier ministre veut remettre à plat
les régimes spéciaux des retraites dans
le secteur public
jamais les partenaires sociaux
n'accepteront de revenir sur leurs
acquis considéré comme historique
après plusieurs semaines de grève le
projet d'alain juppé est remise au
placard 7 million et demi de personnes
bénéficient de départ en retraite
spécifique
parmi eux les transports publics
il concerne uniquement la sncf et la
ratp
les salariés peuvent partir dès 55 ans
voire 50 ans pour les conducteurs avec
plus de 25 ans de maison
autre entreprise au régime spécifique
edf gdf la retraite à 55 ans concerne
les emplois dits à risque soit un
salarié sur deux il s'agit des poseurs
de ligne des ouvriers ou encore des
personnels des centrales nucléaires à la
poste seuls les facteurs et les agents
du tri postal de vienne retraités à 55
ans le reste du personnel par à 60 ans
enfin dans la fonction publique les
policiers cessent leur activité à 55 ans
sous comme les cantonniers ou encore les
instituteurs pour les militaires le
départ peut même se faire à 35 ans
mais pour une retraite partielle en tout
il existe une vingtaine de régimes
spéciaux dans le secteur public aucun
projet de réforme n'est à l'ordre du
jour